the weaker Hurricane durian now taking
aim at southeastern Massachusetts as it
moves toward eastern Canada durian is
about 145 miles southeast of Nantucket
with 85 mile an hour winds it is moving
northeast at 25 miles an hour
boats were pulled from the water in
Hyannis Massachusetts on Friday and
ferries waive their fees to bring
residents on nearby islands back to the
mainland the monster storm is blamed for
at least 43 deaths in the Bahamas it is
a number that officials warn will surely
grow as thousands of people are still
missing in the storm ravaged Outer Banks
of North Carolina flood waters have
receded Omar Villafranca is in Kitty
Hawk with the latest this morning on
durian Omar good morning good morning
and what a difference a day makes 24
hours ago the wind gusts here were
whipping at about 80 miles an hour where
I'm standing right here the surf was up
to my knees but now durian has moved
farther up the coast but the after
effects are still being felt here in
North Carolina video taken by sheriff's
deputies shows an overhead view of the
destruction left by hurricane durian as
the storm passed through coastal North
Carolina 95 year old Thelma Horner
nearly lost part of her home when wind
gusts ripped this 80-foot tree off the
ground I'm glad that it's in the street
not in the yard heavy winds on the Outer
Banks ripped siding off homes and
snapped telephone poles in half rough
surf from durian washed away a third of
this long standing pier first responders
are conducting rescue missions in
heavily flooded Ocracoke Island an
estimated 800 residents defied
evacuation orders for the island which
is only accessible by air or boat
it's coming into the house governor Roy
Cooper described the flooding as
catastrophic currently the island has no
electricity and many homes and buildings
are still under water drain bans are
expected to track over southeastern
Massachusetts with possible wind gusts
reaching 73 miles per hour officials in
New Jersey and New York have banned
swimming and surfing at their beaches
while Dorian makes its way to Canada
the National Weather Service predicts
ocean swells as large as 10 feet but
some locals are not as worried I mean
it's been a conflict because most
surfers are waiting for hurricanes Bob
lifeguards and law enforcement are
expected to patrol those beaches to
enforce that ban and there is a coastal
flood warning for DC Maryland and
Virginia until further notice Dana Omar
that shot when we saw you when we
started just chillingly beautiful if you
think about it with all that destruction
left behind thank you for the report
absolutely